so hello my name is Sebastian
Ballesteros I'm 19 years old and I am a
screenwriter I've been a screenwriter
for about move I'd say four years of my
life I think it was it started about
sophomore year of high school when I you
know when I finally got around to
writing my first script and I remember
was so excited because it came out of
the printer and I took it out and I took
a look at it and it was this sort of
this special moment it was the physical
manifestation of my expression you know
the poetic way to say it would be like
that my idea have has been you know
turned into a physical thing in the
physical world I thought that it was
just such a special process that you
don't get to appreciate as often but now
the current script I'm working on I've
been working on it for about a year the
actual inception of the thing came away
before that when I had a bunch of other
ideas that just came together to make
this one I was going through some things
in high school that through some
feelings I might say that I wasn't quite
sure how what to make of what to make of
them you know and and through
screenwriting through through through my
personal expression I I was able to to
interpret those feelings through a story
and it was so relieving when I finally
did that and and you know what came out
was actually a what I think is a pretty
decent story about desire lust um guilt
and and and really not knowing what you
have in front of you not knowing what
what what not know how to appreciate
what you had in front of you and now the
reason that I haven't quit is
essentially because because of because
it is so personal to me because it is
such an extension of my fee
wings you know that I just can't let it
go which is one of my personal flaws I
can't let things go over easily so you
know I most of the stories i right are
just about the past or about high school
or about the things that I didn't get to
do even if it's just like a journal
entry and it's something that you know
the past is something that really
resonates with me and the contrast
between past and present so and the
short answer really is because it's so
personal to me that I just can't let it
go now my goal with this script is
hopefully to take it to college take it
to the University because I'm in
community college right now so once I
transfer I'll be able to find
like-minded people will help me actually
make the thing a lesson screenwriting
has taught me it's essentially that you
know and the broader sense of things
that art it's very undervalued that that
storytelling in today's society is
extremely undervalued because people see
movies as a way to go and entertain
themselves but what they really should
be thinking about is that movies are are
these treasure chests of wisdom writing
this particular screenplay I realized
that a film could be just so much more
than just entertainment I actually sit
down to write very sparingly because I
have so many ideas just jumbled up in my
head that I just need to pour them out
and when I do I I do it pretty fast and
you know it comes out rather not not
clean at all but it comes out and then
next session I can you clean it up my
screenwriting goals are essentially that
what I've mentioned before with with
looking at as art as a way to learn I
just hope that one of my films one day
someone will see it
and they'll learn something just with
that I'll be satisfied that story
actually I i remember you know the first
screenplay that i wrote that i told you
about I came out of the printer I gave
it to a friend that I really trusted and
he is very intelligent too so he knows
what he's talking about I got it back a
couple days later and I see it and it's
just covered and his handwriting you
know I can't I can't I always can't see
the dialogue that I wrote because he's
written over and he's crossed so many
things out and and and you know at first
I thought I sort of freaked out because
I sure was thought it was good and then
I realized that it wasn't and and it
really taught me that that uh I know
nothing you know I know one thing that I
know nothing really so thank you I
appreciate you guys doing this very much
best of luck to everyone who is
participating in this you know me the
best writer win and and good luck to
everyone who's watching thank you very
much